what's going on guys the summer movie
season is coming to a close
Labor Day is just about here kids are
going back to school they're gonna be
less explosions in the upcoming movies
more Oscar buzz and we're gonna talk
about what we have in store and we've
got an awesome panel to discuss it with
we've got the dream team profiles with
Malone and manse let's say hi to him so
she's been on the show before you can
check her out
movies are my jam on YouTube Alicia
Malone
hi thanks for having me back oh thank
you for coming back and wearing a real
movie nerd t-shirt and also wearing a
really nerdy movie shirt you know from
Access Hollywood as well as profiles
with Malone and mats
Scott Matz it's great to be here my very
first time doing screen junkies here
with my partner in crime on profiles
this is a very very fun so we're calling
it fall movies but we're basically
taking it towards the end of the year
and there are several titles that we're
all looking forward to star wars the new
James Bond movie Spectre Hunger Games
Mockingjay part 2 hateful eight love
Tarantino but we're gonna tell people
what else we're looking forward to so
let's kick this off Alicia well I'm
gonna cheat a bit and talk about one
that I've already seen I saw it at the
Cannes Film Festival
it's Sicario and that comes out
September and week one Emily Blunt
Benicio del Toro Josh Brolin and it's
directed by Denis Villeneuve who did
prisoners and enemies yes so what's got
you excited about Sicario it has that
same breakneck pace as prisoners I mean
prisoners I almost sued myself damaged
because I didn't want to go to pee I
didn't know that it was so exciting what
a battle that is when you're at a movie
what it really picks is Sicario same
thing did not want to move from my chair
Emily Blunt delivers an incredible
performance I wouldn't be surprised if
she's nominated for Sicario Scott give
us one that you're really proud I'm
really pumped about Black Mass this is
directed by Scott Cooper who did crazy
heart which won an Oscar for Jeff
Bridges yeah I also did a movie that not
enough people saw called out of the firm
yeah I like that
Christabel very happy I agree
really
pretty intense and this film Johnny Depp
he plays the South Boston gangster James
Whitey Bulger they're both based on a
true story one of the most notorious
gangsters in the country is nobodies
easy didn't happen what's the last time
you really saw Johnny Depp in an
oscar-worthy performance that didn't
have the word pirates in the tie dude I
am hoping I am hoping this is a return
to form quality acting cautiously
optimistic and if you want to learn more
about Whitey Bulger there's a great
Bulger documentary on Netflix as well
that's right Alicia what's another one
that you're really excited another
gangster film I'm really looking forward
to legend which is our October 2nd and
it stars double Tom Hardy so he plays
both these Krave twin brothers who
wreaked havoc in the in London in 1650
60s yeah they kind of ran the underworld
it's really stylish and from what I've
heard from people who've seen the film
it you completely get sucked into the
idea of Tom Hardy playing two different
people laughing now yeah are you mad Tom
Hardy is just I love that guy everything
he does it's kind of actor like you just
know that he's gonna win an Oscar one of
these days really really yeah he's like
a brand I doesn't movie that I'm
actually looking for - yes they already
saw just recently was 99 homes it's a
snapshot of our current times with the
real estate bust and Michael Shannon
plays a real estate broker who owns all
these homes he's very very wealthy but
he is the kind of sort of bad guy you'd
love to hate because there's there's a
method to his madness and the way he
kicks these people out of their homes
America doesn't bail out the losers
America was built by bailing out winners
so it's a study of ethics
it's a mortally complex drama both
performances michael shannon antje
garfield are fantastic matt's putting
you on the spot are you saying Oscar
buzz well I'm saying there should be it
should be it's a very small film or
flashy enough to get your attention but
if you got nominated
we'd be happy Alicia another one help us
out well I am a big know when it comes
to reading books take books and about to
be turned into movies yeah there's one
that I read cold room
it's by Emma Donoghue and it's being
made into a film coming out October 16th
[Music]
Rumia part yeah Tammy partly shot this
one stars brie Larson and she plays a
mother to a young son who was born
inside this one-room what happens why
they were kidnapped when she was younger
she had this child within the room so
that's the only thing that he knows is
this one room and it's an escape story
for them another movie that's based on a
book this one's a very popular book the
Martian written by Andy weir which I
almost finished yeah a lot of people
love the book the scope opens October
2nd directed by one of my all-time
favorite filmmakers Ridley Scott's Matt
Damon stuck on Mars and he's a botanist
so he has to figure out a way to make
his resources last until the earth NASA
could come back and pick him up and
rescue him it is kind of weird though
that he played a guy stranded on a
planet in interstellar and he's doing
that in this light interstellar or
spoiler alert if you haven't seen
interstellar he plays a bad astronaut
yeah you know this one he plays a good
astronaut it does look and feel like
ever turn to form for Ridley sky it's
been a while since he's had like a
really really great movie I'm so rooting
for this to be that return to form
because I loved her at least guys
absolutely I'm also looking forward to
spotlight which comes out on November
the 6th talk about great casts yes as
Michael Keaton Mark Ruffalo Rachel
McAdams oh and they play Boston
Journalists newspaper journalist so are
uncovering the Catholic Church and the
alleged child abusers that way so it's
kind of feel similar to all the
President's Men which you always say
when it comes to newspaper dramas you
know a lot of people are saying that
with Birdman Michael Keaton was robbed
of that Oscar maybe this could be
another shot at the Oscar regardless I
just love saying Michael Keaton on
screen I'm so glad he's back on screen
he might get robbed to get by Eddie
Redmayne and the Danish girl yeah it's
fantastic
perhaps walk the walk walk the walk it
comes out September 30th this is like to
buy another one of my all-time favorite
directors Robert Zemeckis this is based
on the true a
it's a true high-wire act so to speak
when Philippe Petit Frenchman walked on
a tightrope between the twin towers in
74 great documentary man on why our
oscar-winning documentary from 2008 so
this is the Joseph gordon-levitt plays
Philippe Petit it looks like a horror
film for anyone who hates Heights that
would be her it's actually gonna be an
exciting kind of fall into winter for
Joseph gordon-levitt he's also in that
Oliver Stone film about Edward Snowden
yeah that's another actor who's poised
for Oscar consideration really really
fast yeah well he's got a couple of
possible entrance into the race yeah
sure does any others that you guys are
super pumped about that we haven't
spoken about my last one that I would
say I'm really excited about November 6
Trumbo and me being a huge fan of old
Hollywood this looks so fascinating yeah
it's wearing a dark period in Hollywood
history exactly the Hollywood 10
blacklist with communism in this film
Bryan Cranston plays Dalton Trumbo who
was a screenwriter who's blacklisted but
then he continued to write and he
actually wrote some pretty famous films
under a pseudonym so it looks like it's
really interesting explores a part of
Hollywood that I'm fascinated about Plus
Bryan Cranston he's such a great actor
I've been waiting for him to get this
kind of meaty role yes I can't wait to
see that one so radical me fight the
purity of Jesus but the rich guy wins
with the cunning of Satan and last for
me as Steve Jobs yet Michael Fassbender
playing the legend himself Steve Jobs
the movie covers three chapters in his
life and his work really what makes this
movie appeal to me the most is that it's
written by Aaron Sorkin yes I mean
putting this up putting this material in
Sorkin's hands that's exciting because
what do you think it was social network
Facebook interesting that's why I
witness was directed by David Fincher
which it was going to be originally and
it had a lot of production problems now
I'm hosting it ends up being great well
what's making it what's what bodes well
in that factor Alicia is that it's
directed by Danny Boyle who's the
oscar-winning director of Slumdog
Millionaire movie won best picture can
spot and get Frank's body
Danny Boyle what's great about he's so
versatile he
does not make the same movie twice
always does something different yeah
gotcha I'm gonna throw out a couple of
titles that I'm personally excited about
that you guys didn't mention I just want
to hear any thoughts the revenant cannot
wait for this movie and ER and retune
yeah in a rude - coming off Birdman yeah
haughty as well hardy there was
something recently this movie sounded
like it was a very troubled production
they were filming in the middle of
nowhere they go over way over budget way
over way past the shooting schedule but
you know listen making movies is not
easy and Alejandro interview 2 is
obviously a visionary it just looks so
intense it does and it looks like it
doesn't let up me or DiCaprio will
hopefully get nominated for this why
yeah yeah I think he's overdue it's a
guy gotta do to win an Oscar seriously
no hope at all for creed until I saw the
trailer I presume I thought was gonna be
about young Apollo Creed I didn't
realize it was his son play by Michael B
Jordan and he's coached by Rocky Balboa
oh yeah this guy yeah that's the
toughest opponent you're ever gonna have
to face I believe that's true Lorraine
and I think that's true life and one
more crimson peak I'm really excited
bout that Guillermo de Toro taking kind
of supernatural and horror material yes
his own like a haunted house kind of
film a return to Gothic form Fukuyama's
del Toro
I mean you betcha cows car is fantastic
also Tom Hiddleston Jessica Chastain
right cast it's the kind of movie that I
know I'll be terrified watching it but I
cannot wait to see it because of that
pedigree ghosts are real
this much I know can't wait to go to the
movies guys what are you excited about
what movie are you most excited to see
let us know in the comments section
below
best answer most original answer will
send you a screen junkies t-shirt I
gotta thank Malone Matt's movies magic
Majesty moments more M words
Alicia Malone thank you so much Scott
movie mats thank you thank you for being
here on the screen junkies very first
time yeah um certainly not in the last
yes right next week don't think we
forgot about the summer we are going to
do our summer box-office wrap-up I do
not think I won it was a rough one it
was a rough one
I want to thank you for watching screen
junkies I'm how Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye-bye everyone remembered the
stars too Michael take Fox Christopher
Lloyd and Elijah Wood yep use your hands
that's like a baby's toy